[Music]
line up the top seven u.s carriers by
size and this is how it looks today
but jetblue's 3.8 billion dollar deal to
buy spirit airlines last month would
change this picture
the tie up would see spirit folded into
jetblue moving jetblue one rung up the
ladder past alaska
you know the word they've used is turbo
charges and that's probably right that
you know if they're able to get this
deal done it really puts them in a
different class really quickly but the
so-called big four american united delta
and southwest would maintain their
places
if you look at what this is it's really
an acquisition about assets it's about
jetblue acquiring
spirit for aircraft and for the crew
members who will operate those aircraft
the question is can a bigger jetblue
compete and how
let's take a look at a few key metrics
to see where the company stands now
where it will be if the deal goes
through and if there could be a big five
[Music]
first pilots
anyone who's been to an airport recently
knows that travel is rough right now
one of the challenges airlines have
started to grapple with this summer
there aren't enough pilots
globally demand for pilots is projected
to exceed supply by 2024 but in north
america it's already here and airlines
are scrambling to both hire and retain
employees
you've seen carriers like spirit uh
frontier allegiant jet blue blues pilots
uh who were who's choosing to go to
united american delta southwest
and so this is really a way for jeff
blue to basically acquire a cadre of
pilots to really
fuel that growth by adding spirit jet
blue would jump from having around 3 800
pilots to nearly 6 600 that's still
about half of delta's industry-leading
13 180 pilots having more pilots it just
gives them a lot more depth and so when
they go into a new market you know they
can offer multiple flights a day instead
of maybe just one or they can go into
more new markets where they're not
already present and you that just makes
them a potentially more meaningful
competitor jetblue would also benefit
from the type of pilots the deal brings
jetblue and spirit both fly mostly
airbus aircraft to have pilots who are
already type rated and qualified to fly
an airbus a320 or an a321
um simplifies things and really reduces
cost for a jetblue
next up fleet
without its deal for spirit jetblue has
a total of 282 jets in its fleet putting
it well behind the big four getting
planes it's just difficult for airlines
right now there's delays and deliveries
manufacturing delays um so just the idea
of just quickly acquiring a couple
hundred planes was very enticing for
jetblue so acquiring spirits all airbus
fleet would give jetblue a total of 458
planes jetblue says with some 300 more
on order it would take it many years i
think they've said eight years to sort
of get to that size that they need to
get organically so
they kind of looked around and deciding
really the best way to kind of jump to a
size that can even begin to compete with
these these bigger airlines is through
an acquisition these planes won't fly as
is though spirit's yellow will be
painted over and jetblue has said it
would take seats off spirit's packed
planes to bring them in line with
jetblue's roomier model
but even taking seats away this deal
would bring jetblue thousands more seats
total
so let's talk about seats
to see how the airline stacks up it's
best to look at a metric known as
available seat miles this metric is
calculated by multiplying the number of
seats available on a given flight by the
number of miles that plane will travel
the more asms you have the more capacity
you have so it's a great metric to show
the size from a capacity standpoint of
an airline in 2021 jetblue had 54
billion available seat miles combining
with spirits 40 billion would edge the
airline closer to 4th place southwest
than 6th place alaska
but even with spirit jetblue's slice of
overall seat capacity will sit at 8
percent analysts say to grow that
jetblue will need to expand its reach i
think what really is needed for jetblue
to get its share
um closer to that of southwest
united delta in america is to set up
some sort of a focus city
with material size in the middle of the
country and lastly destinations
currently jetblue flies to 98
destinations spirit flies to 90. the
combined airline wouldn't fly to 188
however that number is more like 127
according to jetblue often in airline
mergers in the past you know regulators
say well this is where you overlap we
need you to cut certain um
you know gates at airports or you know
need you to divest some assets in order
to so so there's not so much overlap if
the deal is allowed to go forward there
will likely be some pruning at least
127 destinations would move jetblue just
above southwest which currently flies to
121 locations the other three would all
have more than double jetblue's
destinations
the deal would make fort lauderdale
jetblue's busiest airport according to a
cerium analysis the combined airline
would then surpass southwest and delta
to become florida's second busiest
carrier by seats after american florida
has been especially the last couple of
years just one of the busiest places in
the country
to fly it is important to airlines to
have a meaningful presence there and
growing there can be really advantageous
for them jetblue says its larger
presence in cities like fort lauderdale
would drive down prices for flyers
however jetblue would be taking an ultra
low cost carrier out of the equation and
some argue that less competition could
end up raising prices for all
proving that competition and low prices
will remain after the deal will be key
to getting regulators to bless the
merger jetblue has argued that the
government has allowed the creation of
four really big airlines that dominate
the market by allowing all these mergers
and that the only way to address that
situation is to allow another carrier to
kind of bulk up and get big enough to
challenge those four big airlines spirit
and former suitor frontier had
previously argued that regulators would
almost certainly prevent a merger
between spirit and jet blue and that the
review process could hobble spirit for
up to two years jetblue has said that
any deal including the failed
combination between spirit and frontier
would face similar levels of pushback
from regulators jetblue expects the deal
to receive approval and be finalized by
the first half of 2024 followed by a
four to five year integration process
and analysts say an even longer time
before it might truly challenge the big
four
it won't be five years from now it won't
be ten years from now but i think what
this does is create a combined airline
that becomes competitive with those big
four and really makes
the the future jetblue relevant in the
industry
[Music]